[Musique]
telle une d'anciens militaires qui fait
toujours réagir le chef d'état-major des
armées promet des sanctions contre les
auteurs de cette tribune je souhaite que
leur mise à la retraite d'office soit
décidée c'est une procédure
exceptionnelle que nous lançons
immédiatement à la demande de la
ministre des armées
cette tribune fait plus d'émoi dans le
débat public et auprès des ministres que
les émeutes que nous vivons depuis
depuis maintenant des semaines donc
c'est quand même surprenant
hier j'ai eu fabre bernadac vous savez
le monsieur cahuzac a lancé ça ils me
disaient qu'ils étaient à dix mille deux
cent dix mille windsor sur la pétition
militaires qui ont signé et pas que des
généraux il me disait qu'il y avait
aussi des deuxièmes places qui avait
signé trouvé ça intéressant quand on a
des militaires qui font une tribune
aussi grave sur l'état de la société qui
est manifestement soutenu par une partie
non négligeable de l'armée puisqu'il ya
tous les jours des signataires qui
arrive compris des soldats du rang ça
dit quelque chose de la société ça
représenterait 4 est marginale ça
représente 0 01 % des militaires
d'actifs qui ont signé cette tribune
et si on parle des généraux à la
retraite nous avons 5200 généraux à la
retraite en france et là il ya à peu
près 25 signataires donc c'est 0 5% des
généraux à la retraite et puis selon
notre sondage exclusif harris
interactive pour lci près de six
français sur dix
dix militaires j'aurais peut-être pas
écrite comme ça mais moi je pense qu'on
ne peut pas uniquement s'attacher au
fait de dire nous allons poursuivre ou
sanctionner ces militaires en oubliant
ce qui est écrit ce qui est écrit c'est
une réalité frau arrière dérapage en
plein centre ville de lyon plusieurs
individus bravent le couvre-feu pour
réaliser des rodéos urbains sous les
fenêtres du maire maire écologiste qui à
mon avis un centre dans la polémique
mais plutôt que de passer sans en
abriter qu'il pour de france
la patrouille de france les sapins et et
la viande dans les cantines j'espère
qu'avec ces images là il va s'attaquer
durablement aux plats de joie à la
sécurité a réagi sur twitter à ses
images
nos équipes de police et de
vidéosurveillance sont déjà mobilisés
pour l'identification et l'arrestation
des délinquants de la place des terreaux
et de la place bellecour
nous ne laisserons pas passer ces
attitudes ni ici ni ailleurs à lyon faut
arrêter à chaque fois de nous faire des
lois on fait des lois en fait d arsenal
juridique qui ne servent à rien donc il
y en a peut-être offert encore un
arsenal juridique nos lois non ça c'est
que du pipeau imaginez deux mains qu'un
de ses petits abrutis se trouvent mal
parce que ton par terre se blesse ou
meurs si sur l'intervention du puzzle de
la police qui interviendrait là mais les
mêmes les mêmes qui aujourd'hui sûrs d'y
regarder ce qu'il faut et où ils eurent
leur et sur les flics sur les policiers
ils sont responsables ce pauvre gamin
qui est mort alors qu'il ne faisait que
ça et on en saura plus sur les
déplacements inter régions et sur la
levée progressive des mesures sanitaires
demain emmanuel macron devrait annoncer
les différentes dates de réouverture
dans une interview à la presse régionale
mais le calendrier a fuité dès cet après
midi
première étape le 3 mai la levée
notamment des restrictions de
déplacement
puis rendez vous le 19 couvre-feu
repoussé à 21h et réouverture des
commerces et terrasses lundi dernier le
conseil municipal de paimpol a
clairement dérapé alors qu'un adjoint
s'exprime un conseiller municipal
d'opposition invectives la maire de la
ville alors qu'il n'a pas la parole j'ai
le droit de répondre mais phase où il va
pas m'empêcher de parler
la jeune femme répondent et le ton
contre vous me parlez pas comme ça le
règlement intérieur ou même plus encore
une fois maîtresse je vous demande de
sortir du conseil municipal
troisième étape le 9 juin avec un
couvre-feu qui passera à 23 heures la
source de mon du télétravail et la
réouverture des restaurants en groupe de
six personnes maximum
et enfin le 30 juin c'est open bar ce
sera la fin du couvre-feu et des georges
dans les lieux recevant du public